self-improvement is not a destination
it's a journey
it needs practice and devotion
here are five hard to learn but really
important skills to improve your life
exponentially
one
being honest with yourself
the Journey of self-improvement starts
with being honest with yourself
it takes courage to tell yourself the
truth that you aren't perfect and you
must improve
most of the people would rather
mindlessly scroll social media or divert
their mind in meaningless things then
accept that their way of living is
lacking something and they must improve
so if you are not satisfied with your
life and want to improve your life start
by being honest with yourself
except you aren't perfect and
communicate with yourself know your
strength and weakness and put effort in
the things you want to improve
two
communication skill
communication is one of the most
important skill you can develop
the ability to say the things you want
to say the way you want to is priceless
proper communication skills will help
you in business networking dating and
many more
the most effective way to improve
communication skill is practicing
talking with people in every situation
possible
it will remove anxiety and fear attached
and train you to communicate effectively
three
time management
it sounds lame but time management is
one of the most underrated skill that
everyone should learn
managing time for work family and for
self is one of the hardest tasks in this
Modern Age
being busy doesn't mean being effective
with proper time management we can
complete our tasks in desired amount of
time and give time to ourselves and our
families
balancing work and play is important
nowadays people overwork or overplay and
the consequences follow
journaling and making routine are some
of the ways for Effective time
management
4.
consistency
in the world run by instant
gratification being consistent is the
key for improving life and long-term
success
self-improvement is not a destination
but a journey of consistently improving
yes you will fail at some point or you
will feel discouraged as you don't see
desired results but the one who keeps
working no matter what believing in
themselves and improving will eventually
get the desired results and success
the most effective way of being
consistent is to focus more on process
of improving than being perfect
five
being present in the moment
I can't stress this much but being
present in the moment is the most
hardest skill to learn yet most easiest
thing to do for us as human beings
being present in the moment is supposed
to be our default state but nowadays we
rarely are present in the moment as we
are constantly thinking about the past
that has already passed by the future
that is uncertain or holds infinite
possibilities
by thinking about past or future we are
depriving ourselves from all the
opportunity and beauty that life
provides us now
meditation is one of the most effective
way to train our mind to be present in
the moment
stop thinking about the past you can't
change or stop worrying about the future
that you can't know and just relax and
breed the soothing beauty of presence
and just live
you deserve this